people like Chris Hayes they aren't used
to seeing Republicans wield power and
fight back especially on cultural issues
because I mean the GOP in my lifetime
has delivered you know tax cuts and
endless Wars and that's about it so I
think you know for the first time to see
conservatives wading into the cultural
issues and pushing back and fighting
this totally nut stuff is really
important and I think it's it shocks the
left because they're not used to it but
we need to do more of it because if you
don't have a culture you don't have a
country it's because when they say boo
when they call you racist or sexist or
homophobic then they get everyone on the
right to immediately cave to whatever
demands they have because they
understand that they do wield the power
of most of the journalists and all of
the all of that complex in this country
so if you have the power of ten thousand
journalists who can use a bunch of
buzzwords and names to call you you
wield a lot of power to stop people from
proposing bills that they want to
propose from speaking out on social
media in the ways they want to